President Trump talks about the NFL's
new ban on kneeling during the national
anthem plus we meet the most entitled 30
year old in America and bring you the
latest on spy he gates 2018 I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
allowed to get to you today and we were
will be talking about all of it first I
want to say thanks to our sponsor is
over at movement so do you see this
watch this one right here this
magnificent piece of hardware okay this
right here is a movement watch and I
wear it every single day in fact I have
to movement watches my wife has a
movement watch my mom has a movement
watch my father has a movement watch
everybody the office has movement watch
not just because they are sponsors but
because they make great watches at
affordable prices movement has come
pretty far from being a bunch of
crowdfunded kids working out of living
room in the past year they've not only
introduced a ton of new watch
collections from both men and women but
also expanded to sunglasses in fashion
for bracelets for women ok these watches
are there they're simple and clean
looking they really look like much more
expensive watches they begin in just 95
bucks at a department store these things
cost four hundred five hundred dollars
Moomin figured out that by cutting out
the middleman they can save you a lot of
money classic design quality
construction style minimalism I can tell
you these things are super durable
because my son loves them and that means
that he throws them around and they look
just as good as new every time he does
it get 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to MVM
t-dot-com slash appear oh that's MVM
t.com slash up arrow again 15% off today
free shipping free returns for movement
MVM t.com slash shapiro you should join
the movement because it is that good use
that slash shapiro let them know he's
saying you get 15% off okay so the big
news of the day is that the NFL has
decided that they will no longer allow
players to come out on the field and
kneel for the national anthem which is I
think a good move by the NFL although I
think it's done in the worst possible
way and they should have done it
originally the NBA had this problem
years ago when there's a player named
Muhammad Abdul Rauf who Mahmoud Abdul
Rauf he was a he was a for a guard I
believe for the Denver Nuggets and he
didn't want to stand up for the national
anthem he was fine and pretty quickly
he ended up standing for the national
anthem Steve Nash refused to put his
hand over his heart for the national
anthem I believe he was fined as well
the NBA's always had this rule the NFL
never should have allowed the
politicization of its games it is a
product when your product is politicized
then you take action to prevent that
politicization but the NFL wanted to
reach out to new audiences and so not
only did they support the politicization
they actually forwarded the
politicization even before the national
anthem protests if you recall all the
way back to 2013
in 2014 during the ferguson issues in
2014 there are a bunch of players who
ran out onto the field doing the hands
up don't shoot motion no fine but there
were people who wanted to wear gear that
honored the slain Dallas police officers
in 2015 and the NFL threatened to find
them before the NFL backed down so the
NFL took positions on these issues in
the worst and stupidest possible way
well now the NFL has decided they're
gonna come out and ban the kneeling
altogether ESPN reports the new policy
subjects teams to a fine if a player or
other team personnel do not show respect
for the anthem that includes any attempt
to sit or kneel as dozens of players
have done during the past few seasons
those teams will also have the option to
find any team personnel including
players for the infraction so Roger
Goodell who I think has been rather a
not good NFL Commissioner actually he's
been the beneficiary of tremendous
growth in the NFL I'm not sure that's
because of Roger Goodell however he said
this season all League and team
personnel shall stand and show respect
for the flag in the anthem personnel who
choose not to stand for the anthem a
stay in the locker room until after the
anthem has been performed we believe
today's decision will keep our focus on
the game and the extraordinary athletes
who play it and on our fans who enjoy it
and the 32 teams agreed to the following
requirements all team and league
personnel on the field shall stand and
show respect for the flag in the anthem
the game operations manual will be
revised to remove the requirement that
all players be on the field for the
anthem so you can stay in the in the in
the locker room personnel who choose not
to stand from the anthem may stand in
the locker room or a similar location
off the field until after the anthem has
been performed a quote will be fine by
the league of its personnel are on the
field and do not stand and show respect
to the flag in the anthem each club may
develop its own work rules consistent
with the above principles regarding its
personnel who do not stand and show
respect for the flag and the anthem the
Commissioner will impose appropriate
discipline on leaked personnel who do
not stand and show respect for the flag
and the anthem ok so what is the actual
practical effect of that's going to be a
bunch of people are going to stay in the
locker room out of solidarity with
people who would kneel but we're not
allowed to as I said last year during
the actual national anthem controversy I
think it is stupid and counterproductive
Tim you for the national anthem I think
it is disrespectful but I don't think
that players should do anything beyond
if they want to stand with their with
their fellows they should just stand
with their fellows instead of kneeling
with their fellows they should stand
there and and put their hand on their
shoulder something like that and I think
what you will see is solidarity with
these guys and a lot of people will now
stay in the locker room so we'll get to
rehash this entire controversy all over
again or things will get even more
and what you will see is a bunch of
players stay in the locker room and the
owners in order to virtue signal to the
left will decide to pay the fines and
that's we're getting from New York Jets
Chairman Christopher Johnson who says
he'll take the hit he said I do not like
imposing any club specific rules if
somebody on the Jets takes a knee that
fine will be borne by the organization
by me not the players I never want to
put restrictions on the speech of our
players so I prefer that they stand of
course but I understand if they felt the
need to protest there are some big
complicated issues that we're all
struggling with and our players aren't
on the front lines I don't want to come
down on them like a ton of bricks and I
won't
there'll be no club fines or suspensions
or any sort of repercussions if the team
gets fine that's just something I'll
have to bear I think you're gonna see a
lot of other owners follow suit and then
owners who don't follow suit will be
called a antagonist of free speech
people who don't support free speech and
this controversy will just continue
while president Trump responded to all
of this by by by celebrating there's a
big victory for president from
culturally and because everything in our
politics has broken down into stupid
conversations over winners and losers as
opposed to what's good for the country
this has turned into a big win for Trump
and Trump not only says that it's a big
win for Trump because Trump got the NFL
to cave and change their policy but it's
a big win for America here's President
Trump explaining you have to stand
proudly for the national anthem
well you shouldn't be playing you
shouldn't be there maybe you shouldn't
be in the country you have to stand
proudly for the national anthem and the
NFL owners did the right thing of that's
what they've done okay so here's the
here's the reality you don't have to
stand for the national anthem in the
United States should you stand sure is
it a sign of respect for the nation yes
and all of the players who are black and
who are protesting about supposed police
brutality against black folks I think
that they would be better served to take
a play from the PlayBook of a Frederick
Douglas or a play from the playbook of
Martin Luther King and say listen I'm
gonna stand for the anthem because the
anthem is mine too and then they can
come out and they can say and I don't
think we're living up to the anthem it's
not like these guys have no platform
they do have a platform when celebrities
speak people listen
but kneeling for the national anthem was
a crude method of attempting to draw
attention and actually created more of a
backlash than it was meant to do I do
not think it is appropriate for the
President of the United States to be
inserting himself in these controversies
I don't I don't think it was appropriate
when Obama did it I don't think it's
appropriate when President Trump does it
President Obama the Obama administration
inserted themselves into controversies
like this in North Carolina when there
is a an act at the local level in
let's to prevent transgender people from
using opposite sex bathrooms and there
was a boycott of the n-c-double-a and
the entire left supported it they
thought this is great the n-c-double-a
was not going to allow final four games
to be played in North Carolina thanks to
a local bathroom policy they thought
this was great but if the NFL says we're
not going to allow people to kneel then
it's a huge problem because the NFL is
cracking down on free speech now listen
I am a free speech absolutist but
private companies have the ability to
take steps to curb free speech okay
there's a difference between me going
and speaking at UC Berkeley and mean
going and speaking into Paul University
when I spoke it to Paul University they
threatened to arrest me they said if you
walk on this campus even though but I've
been invited by a student group they
said if you walk on this campus you will
be arrested and I respected that because
listen it is a private university were
they wrong were they stupid sure do they
have the right to do it you bet they do
now there is also a major difference and
I don't like the comparisons between oh
you conservatives complaining about safe
spaces on college campuses but now you
want a safe space at an NFL game there
is no comparison between a college
campus in an NFL game there really is
not okay for a simple reason
college campuses are explicitly places
for exchange of ideas when I'm invited
by a student group it is not to play
football when I am invited by a stick I
mean I suck at football when I'm invited
by a student group it is specifically to
give my opinion when you go to an NFL
game you are purchasing an entertainment
package to watch the NFL and part and
parcel of that is the patriotic show so
I was at the Super Bowl last year and
the Super Bowl was deeply patriotic
deeply patriotic for those who have
never been to a game it's not just the
national anthem beforehand it's the flu
waving of the flag during the
commercials it's the this was in a
Dillman Stadium but usually it's the
it's the Blue Angels fly over and so the
whole deal the NFL has always been
heavily tied in with a lot of patriotic
imagery that's part of the products that
they are selling to the American people
is that this is the all-american sport
or we get together as a community every
Sunday afternoon and we remember that
America is a great place and we enjoy
ourselves and just watch some people
clock each other that's basically what
football is all about and it's not the
NFL's fault if that product is being
undercut by people on the field and they
say listen we're not going to withstand
the fans who don't want to watch our
games we are not going to withstand the
ticket sales loss and we're not going to
withstand the TV ratings loss okay the
the entire NFL is moving in the
direction of whatever the TV ratings say
and the TV ratings in 2017 were down a
full eight percent that's a significant
significant drop now not all of that is
due to the national anthem controversy
but certainly part of it is due to the
national anthem controversy when there
have been polls done of people who say
they're not watching as much NFL
something like 50 percent of them
cite the national anthem controversy
because they don't feel solidarity with
the players who are kneeling for the
national anthem hey this is not the same
thing as a college campus again it's
more like first of all I'm an outside
contractor who's brought in by a student
group for that free exchange of ideas
again college campuses are for ideas NFL
games are before playing a football and
production of a product and it's more
like if a college campus had a professor
who taught engineering and this
engineering professor decided that they
were going to talk politics at the
beginning of every engineering class and
pretty soon it turns out that all the
students weren't just learn engineering
and they're not interested in hearing
the politics and so they all drop out of
the class does the college now have the
right to lay the guy off in my opinion
the college does have the right to lay
the guy off he's speaking outside of his
realm of Perez politic his political
purview if you were in Poli Sci it's a
little bit of a different story if he's
an engineering he is there to provide an
engineering product if the engineering
product does not meet specifications the
college can do what it wants and that's
not quite the same thing as a student
group inviting someone for a political
conversation and then the college
cracking down on a political side of
that political conversation okay the the
the case that's being made on campus is
that this is a safe space and the people
with differing political points of view
in an inherently political area should
not be able to speak the case being made
with regard to the NFL is I'm not gonna
tune in to watch lectures on police
brutality when I want to watch football
game that is not the same case that's
being made it's not about the NFL being
a safe space it is about the NFL not
providing what it promised to consumers
and that's why you've seen so many
people drop out now with that said you
know Mike Pence tweeted out hashtag
winning I do not think it is appropriate
for government officials to say that it
is winning to pressure a private
organization to crackdown on members of
its organization and for political
reasons I don't think that's appropriate
I think that it's one thing for you or
for me to say I'm turning off the TV I
think if Trump said listen I've been
turning off the TV that's fine I think
the the attempt the pretty clear attempt
governmental attempt to pressure private
organizations to do things on the free
speech basis I
don't like it and I don't think it's
winning by the way I don't think that
you you're winning with your bass you're
winning with your bass but I'll explain
why I think this is actually
counterproductive for Trump and pens to
a certain degree in just one second
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at policy genius so 80% of
people think life insurance costs double
what it actually costs life insurance is
not all that expensive and there is no
excuse for you whatsoever there's no
excuse for you whatsoever not to buy
life insurance because if you plotz
tomorrow you're gonna leave your family
poor and there's no reason for you to do
that when you could go online right now
and get yourself a good health a good
life insurance program and then you
won't have to worry about it ever again
a healthy 35 year old can get half a
million bucks in coverage for less than
30 bucks a month there is no reason that
shouldn't be you policy genius is the
easy way to compare life insurance
online in just five minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers to
find the best policy for you policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage and they
don't just make life insurance easy they
also do renters insurance and disability
insurance and health insurance and all
other kinds of insurance so if you've
been thinking about getting life
insurance go to policy genius comm right
now that's policy genius com it's the
easy way to compare the top insurers and
find the best policy for you you will be
saving time and money and hassle and it
is indeed free policy genius go chair go
check it out
comparing life insurance does not need
to be a pain in the neck policy
genius.com alrighty so here is why I
don't think this is super productive for
President Trump his entire base believes
it is wrong to kneel for the national
anthem he's getting them jazzed up right
and I think that that is a useful
political tactic but in its way it's no
different from what Obama did when he
would get people jazzed up about
Ferguson to go out and vote for him in a
midterm election or in a presidential
election in 2012 by sending Joe Biden
out to say that Mitt Romney was gonna
put y'all back in Chains I do not like
the idea of the President of the United
States taking an inherently political
issue and instead of being circumspect
about the issues that are being that are
there in play going straight to the
everybody who disagrees with me should
be deported stop I think it's dumb I
think it's counterproductive I think it
doesn't unify the country and actually
has a counterproductive response because
here's the question for Trump it's all
about the political win I get it ok he's
a politician it's about the political
win but for the country what I would
like is more Americans to believe that
standing for the national anthem is an
inherent good not fewer Americans the
polls show that before President Trump
got involved in this particular issue
some of the
like 75% 80% of Americans thought that
it was stupid and wrong to kneel for the
national anthem
now that Trump has gotten himself
involved it's more like 55 or 60 percent
so to win for Trump because a majority
the public still agrees with him but it
is not a win for America if 20% of the
public now believes the other way simply
because they don't like President Trump
so again I understand the I understand
the gut level response of President
Trump which is what he is it's what he
does I understand why that's popular but
I don't think that it's productive for
the country now with all of that said it
was not Trump who politicized the NFL it
was the NFL players who politicized the
NFL long before Trump was even involved
with this okay they were the ones who
decided to kneel for the national anthem
they were the ones who decided to wear
socks is colin kaepernick head with a
depiction of cops as pigs that was their
decision to make okay and you can't
blame people for responding to that
decision just as I don't blame
protesters for protesting my speeches
right they are allowed to protest my
speeches that's fine I think they're
wrong but that's okay that's part of the
political conversation well this is part
of the political conversation too again
I do not think that NFL games are
anything like college campuses I'm not
crazy about the idea of the NFL cracking
down on players doing this although I
think they should have done so at the
beginning Jonathan last I thought had a
good suggestion the NFL should have just
come out and said listen our consumers
don't want to see what you are doing our
consumers don't like this so we're
setting rules end of story instead they
turned it into a sort of principled
point and obviously everyone can see
through the principal point everyone can
see through the so-called principals
idea here because it's not really
principled it's much more about the the
notion that they are going to crack down
on players in order to make sure that
their wallets are still stuffed so I get
all of it listen I understand the
arguments I'm just not in love with it I
know a lot of people on the right are
very much in love with this day out two
big wins but I'm not in love with it as
much as everybody else because I see the
danger in private organizations seeing
political speech as a serious problem
although I agree that the NFL's product
is being seriously compromised by all of
us okay meanwhile speaking of people who
need a safe space I have to show you
this tape there's a 30 year old who was
evicted from his home in a in a judicial
proceeding so he's a 30 year old
unemployed man he's a self-described
conservative who was evicted by
parents so the host of CNN Brooke
Baldwin had this guy on this guy's
obviously a crazy person the guy is
named Michael rotondo and it did not go
well for him it's my understanding
you've lived you know at your parents
house rent-free for eight years and I
know you do your own laundry you buy
your own food but they asked you five
times please move out why couldn't you
guys resolve this without the court I
would consider a much of what they were
doing to try to get me out as a tax and
what I was trying to I was just maybe a
little bit longer than we then we wish
we could please take a sip of your water
I'm sure your
I'm sure your parents are earth but you
know you only have one mom and dad and I
and I understand that you are probably
more upset than even you're letting on
but but don't you want to reconcile with
them okay let me let me point out here
that Brooke Baldwin obviously is having
this guy on just to humiliate him and
this is this is not great as a is a
television host you shouldn't have
people on simply to make them look
stupid I think that it's kind of a waste
of time in a waste of everybody's time
that said there's another point here to
be made so CNN is spending an awful lot
of time with this guy they spent like
five ten minutes with this guy talking
about how he wanted to stay home and he
was entitled CNN is very much in favor
of the idea that if you occupy somebody
else's dwelling you should not be
evicted okay they're the ones who are
saying that when banks evict people for
non-payment of their bills
that this is somehow cruel and terrible
people on the left want to have it both
ways they want to say the millennial
generation is entitled when they act
precisely how CNN and MSNBC tell them to
which is your you should mooch off your
parents we were told that until we were
26 we're staying on our parents health
insurance and we should move trough our
parents our parents owe it to us we were
told that if we decide to live in the
home there is nothing wrong with that
you should stay as long as you want you
should be able to squat you should be
able to live on the street you should be
able to do whatever you want this guy
does it and suddenly he's being
castigated for the doofus that he is and
obviously he is a doofus but it does go
to show you how
even the underlying narrative points
that CNN is trying to drive home that
are successful for them in many cases
aren't conservative points it's really
funny when you go and you watch movies
from Hollywood you know Hollywood
obviously a very very left area it's a
place where virtually everybody is
Democrat but if you just watched movies
without knowing the politics of the
people behind it
and you could avoid all of the stupid
insertions of politics into the
particular movies that you are watching
what you would see is actually a very
conservative narrative that's drawn out
in nearly every movie it's usually a
good guy and a bad guy there's a concept
of good and evil it's usually somebody
who comes into conflict and has to
resolve that conflict through a crisis
of will and principle a very
conservative idea well the same thing
happens on CNN right here so CNN if this
were a story about the parents of victim
their son now let's say they come at it
from the other angle this is a story
about a parents trying to get rid of
their son they said look how cruel these
parents are these parents are so cool so
terrible but because they decided to
take the conservative angle it's much
more compelling TV which is why are you
suing your parents to stay in their home
again it's it's hilarious to see so many
folks on the Left who are saying you
should be independent you should get out
of your parents home why are you
bothering your parents and then at the
same time they say well you know what
you really should be deeply dependent on
the government be dependent on the
government be dependent on everyone else
there's nothing wrong with taking a
government check there's nothing wrong
with taking a handout there's nothing
wrong with demanding a handout now they
say this guy's a self-described
conservative but he's acting like a
Bernie Sanders lefty it's Bernie Sanders
lefties who say that I am here therefore
you owe me stuff and that's precisely
the angle that this guy's taking and
CNN's ripping him for it so at some
point I'd like them to ask Bernie
Sanders what this guy did wrong I just
think it'd be really funny like they
could have this guy on with Bernie
Sanders and they could ask Bernie
Sanders if the guy is doing something
truly awful because he's paying his rent
right I mean he's he's doing what he's
supposed to do presumably Bernie Sanders
would stand up for him but CNN is not
standing up for him because even they
understand that there is nothing good
happening there in terms of the useful
okay so before I go any further and talk
about President Trump at North Korea
because he made a pretty major move on
North Korea this morning first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors over at puppy
spots so the best place to find the
perfect puppy is puppy spot calm now
listen I am NOT a dog owner I'm not a
warm and cuddly person but this I do
know if you are going to get a puppy
then this puppy has to be vetted because
I've seen too many case
my grandmother went to the pound she
picked up a dog the dog nearly bitter I
mean it's it's really like this sort of
stuff happens a lot this is why if
you're trying to find a perfect puppy
you need to go to puppy spot calm it's a
trusted service connecting the nation's
top breeders to caring responsible
individuals and families okay puppy spot
is more than a service they're actually
advocates there are 200 plus dog loving
team members ensure that only the
highest level of licensed breeders enter
their exclusive breeder community their
industry leading health guarantee means
your puppy's vaccinations are up to date
and they receive a notices how health
exam from a licensed veterinarian before
they're brought safely home to you there
are a lot of puppy owners in the office
and I asked them to check the tax I
don't know that much about getting a
puppy I don't and they are they look at
it they said it's not only perfectly
legit is actually terrific that if you
were gonna get puppy this is the place
to do it so get your new best friend a
puppy spot calm splash Ben because for a
limited time all Ben Shapiro listeners
actually receive access to the puppy
spot VIP program they've discounts on
everything you need for your new puppy
from food to walking services you're
really like again I'm only laughing
because I'm such not a cuddly person and
the sounds so cuddly that it makes me
awkward like it sounds so cuddly and
wonderful that it just makes me awkward
as a human being so check it out puppy
spot comm slash man you get that special
offer again you'll receive access to the
puppy spot VIP program they've discounts
on everything you need for your new
puppy from food to walking services
puppy spot comm slash Ben I'm so
uncomfortable being emotional in public
that's why this is happening
puppies Baca then use that slash pen let
them know that we say yeah I know there
are a lot of dog lovers in the audience
so I think it'll be great for you puppy
spot comm / ben if only i had a heart
like really fully Adar heart I feel like
I would be using puppy spots calm
unfortunately my heart is three sizes
too small
so I'll have to ask people at the office
to do it for me and then they will know
how great puppy spot is okay so
meanwhile president Trump has gotten
himself in into not a pickle out of a
pickle
I would suggest so I have always been
skeptical of the idea that there was
going to be a grand summit between the
Trump administration and the North
Korean dictatorship I have always been
deeply skeptical of this I was from the
beginning when people were shouting
Nobel Prize Nobel Prize I was saying for
what okay unless North Korea wants to
actually give something up there's no
deal that's gonna get done here and
there's a far better shot that the
United States will make a bad move and
that the bad move will in
pulling troops off the peninsula or
scaling down military drills or making
some sort of promise financially to kim
jeong-hoon which I do not support well
president Trump did the right thing so a
few days ago North Korea threatened a
nuclear showdown with the United States
so this was just a few couple of days
ago North Korea according to Huffington
Post has escalated its war of words with
the u.s. repeating a threat on Thursday
to call off the plan
June 12th summit with President Donald
Trump warning that a nuclear showdown
could instead be on the table and a
statement published by North Korea's
official Korean Central News Agency the
North's Vice Minister of Public Affairs
Cho seung-hui blamed reckless remarks
made by top US officials as the reason
behind Pyongyang's second thoughts Cho
took aim at VP Mike Pence in particular
and calls him a political dummy who
defended North Korea with his unbridled
and imprudent comments and impudent
comments rather pens had warned in a Fox
News interview that Pyongyang could
follow the Libya model if Kim jong-un
does make a deal which was a deal where
Muammar Qaddafi met a brutal end after
his decision to D nuclear eyes okay
North Korea has long expressed his
tastes at comparisons with Libya they
don't want to look like a weak country
they gave up their nuclear weaponry and
all the rest so they were ripping on
Mike Pence and they were suggesting that
they were going to pull out of the June
12 summit and so Trump came out and he
wrote a letter and his letter basically
said fine stay home I don't care which
is exactly right that's exactly right
okay the United States is not the
country in trouble here the country in
trouble here is North Korea and let's
face the reality North Korea is in
trouble because they blew up their own
nuclear mountain it collapsed in on them
weeks ago they do not have a nuclear
testing site inside North Korea because
they had a physical problem with their
nuclear testing site it broke okay they
broke their own testing site which is an
amazing thing and President Trump was
just sitting there and then they're like
can we have some talks he's like
absolutely you can have some talks and
then in order to save face they're
making all sorts of noises about nuclear
war so President Trump this is where
president Trump's have it of being just
a bloviating hammer of a human being it
really comes in handy so here is what he
wrote you have to love this it's so good
he writes dear mr. chairman we greatly
appreciate your time patience and effort
with respect to our recent negotiations
and discussions relative to a summit
alongside by both parties which was
scheduled to take place on June 12th in
Singapore we were informed the meeting
was requested by North Korea but that to
us is totally
relevant I was very much looking forward
to being there with you
sadly based on the tremendous anger and
open hostility displayed in your most
recent statement I feel it is
inappropriate at this time to have this
long planned meeting therefore please
let this letter serve to represent at
the Singapore summit for the good of
both parties but to the detriment of the
world will not take place you talk about
your nuclear capabilities but ours are
so massive and powerful that I pray to
God they will never have to be used okay
that last sentence is so Trump it's so
Trump and it's so great I mean it's like
Donald Trump brags about his genitals
and his nuclear capabilities and exactly
the same one they're so massive and
powerful
I pray to God they would never have to
be it's so good I mean it is the
president of the United States telling
North Koreans guys like let's be real
here you're pretending that this is a
partnership of co-equals then we're
gonna sit down across the table and
we're gonna pretend like North Korea is
a real country and not a crazy
dictatorship where you imprison in a
gulag hundreds of thousands of people
and then test your crappy level nuclear
weapons like we're gonna pretend that
but let's be real we're massive we're
huge you might say and then he continues
I felt a wonderful dialogue was building
up between you and me and ultimately it
is only that dialogue that matters
someday I look very much forward to
meeting you in the meantime I want to
thank you for the release of the
hostages who I don't know home with
their families that was a beautiful
gesture and was very much appreciated
which is him reminding them you guys
already made concessions to me so hah
hah hah hah hah hah hah you idiots you
let out the hostages and now we're not
gonna do a meeting and I'm gonna laugh
about how my nuclear weapons are better
than yours again all of this is kind of
hilarious
cows be real kind of funny does it
chance does it increase the chances of
nuclear war
no because the North Korean regime does
not once you get into nuclear war with
the United States we would turn his
palace into an ocean of glass in 30
seconds flat this is not happening okay
there's not gonna be a war between North
Korea in the United States because Kim
jong-un is not suicidal and all of the
concessions he was prepared to make were
not going to be made because Donald
Trump sweet-talked him this is never
going to be about Donald Trump being
able to cut a better deal than anyone
else or anything like that
okay the art of negotiation does not lie
and you giving somebody a pat on the
head and a shoulder rub that's not how
negotiation works the way it works is
Trump is it ready to walk away from the
table okay this is true for your salary
negotiations at your
own company it is true for everyone you
have to decide in your own head
what is your walkaway point what is the
point where you say listen this is not
worth it for me
I'm out Trump knew that his walkaway
point was pretty much anything then if
North Korea decided to make trouble he
was just gonna say fine
screw it enjoy your poverty-stricken
country we're out and if you make
trouble well guess what our military
threat is still on the table
he continues along these lines if you
change your mind having to do with this
most important summit please do not
hesitate to call me or write the world
in North Korea in particular has lost a
great opportunity for lasting peace and
great prosperity and wealth this missed
opportunity is a truly sad moment in
history Sincerely Yours and then it's
the biggest signature ever like you
almost have to see the signature it's
like the entire page it's like President
Trump was like you know what just so-so
Kim jong-un doesn't need to use his
reading glasses he's gonna use it he's
gonna sign this huge spiky signature the
Donald trum signature that's okay you
can hate Donald Trump as much as you
want that's pretty great stuff this is
what he is supposed to do what's
hilarious is folks on the left are
saying how could Donald Trump do this
how could it just shows how Donald Trump
looat now here's where Donald Trump went
wrong he shouldn't been running around
talking about how he was gonna win the
Nobel Prize for meeting with kim
jeong-hoon before him but that's trump's
thing okay are we gonna pretend for half
a second here
the president Trump isn't the guy who
walks around bragging about everything
have you met him have you seen him of
course as soon as people started saying
Nobel Prize he was gonna go around
talking about how he was about to win
eight Nobel prizes in physics in
literature all of them right he was
gonna like that was going to happen but
here's the I thought that that was
trapping him in a situation where he was
going to have more stake in having the
meeting than in getting something good
out of the meeting that obviously was
not true so if I sound relieved it's
because I am president Obama was not
like this
President Obama was willing to grant
every shred of credibility he could to a
terrorist regime in Iran just so he
could say that he got a deal and he was
a great peace maker he was not willing
to walk away from the table because his
interest was in the deal itself
president Trump's interest I was
skeptical about this but it is isn't
making a good deal
it isn't making a better deal I'm very
much heartened by president Trump's
willingness to walk away from the table
with kim jeong-hoon because i don't
think that it was smart for him to put
it out there that we were gonna meet
with kim jeong-hoon without
preconditions in the first
place I don't think it was smart to walk
into a room not knowing what we wanted
from kim jeong-hoon i'm very happy that
he said listen my walk away point was
right here you passed it we're out good
good now maybe it was preemptive okay to
be skeptic maybe who's pre-emptive maybe
he figured the North Koreans we're gonna
cancel he wanted to cancel first it was
more of a you can't you can't fire me I
quit maybe it was that maybe that's what
was going on but whatever it was at
least Trump was willing to say that and
you gotta love the tude right you gotta
love the attitude because the attitude
is just spectacular
it is indeed high larious it is so good
it's I can enjoy it okay I can enjoy it
well in just a second I'm gonna give you
the update on all on this inside I have
to talk to you about this judicial
decision about Trump's Twitter feed
because it's just ridiculous but first I
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
at software advice so you're dealing
with a real head-scratcher with your
go-to person on a call because you don't
have the right software okay you like
you're running a business you don't know
what software to use I'm an ignoramus
about software and I don't even know who
to ask about software right I have
people who work for me who have to
decide what kind of software we use at
our company because we use a bunch of
different types of software well this is
why you need software advice when it
comes to picking the right software for
your business software advice has done
all of the research for you their team
of advisors can point you in the right
direction so you can start working more
effectively right away it is absolutely
free all you do is go to software advice
comm slash pen and you interested are a
few short questions about your business
and then you are connected with an
advisor to discuss the best software
options for your needs you know a lot of
the time you think that it's your
employees aren't doing the right amount
of work they're not working properly I
promise you half the problems at your
company are probably technological
particularly if you haven't updated your
software in a little while I mean we
save a lot of money here at the company
by using updated software on a regular
basis this is why you need software
advice.com so check it out whether
you're a medical professional a
construction manager and HR / oh you
should go to software advice.com slash
pen and you can talk to an advisor in
just 10 minutes or less it says it take
10 minutes or less to talk to someone
who can help your business and save you
you know I really think serious time in
serious dollars and that software
struggled today go to software
advice.com slash Ben to get started that
software at vice.com slash Ben's
connects with an advisor for free
software advice.com
slash man again this is where you can
get your software advice so it is
well-named so check it out software
advice calm
and that lets them know that we sent you
upgrade your business now you can get
all the advice you need right now
instead of having to shop around talk to
10,000 people don't do that go to
software advice calm /ban okay so I do
want to talk about the latest on the so
called Trump scandals I want to talk
about in an insane and ridiculous
Twitter controversy but first we're
gonna have to go over to Daily wires for
$9.99 a month go over today Lee Weyer at
the subscription my show claiming the
show Knowles the show get all of those
things past the pay wall which is great
and you also get to be part of the
mailbag which we'll be doing tomorrow
here i'm ben shapiro show which is a
blast you also get first access to our
event so we have events coming up in
phoenix and dallas nearly sold out daily
wired.com slash events daily wire.com
slash events to get the tickets now but
if you'd been a subscriber then you
would have been the first to have access
to those so our VIPs are sold out I
believe in both places at this point so
it's too late for you now I think but if
you've been a subscriber then you would
have had first access likely all of our
VIP tickets sold out before the tickets
were even open to non subscribers so if
you want to be a VIP ticket holder you
basically have to subscribe so go check
that out right now for $99 a year you
get the annual subscription which comes
along with this the very greatest in all
beverage vessels look at this
magnificent piece of vessel REE it is
just it is astonishing when you drink
from this your health is restored your
mind is restored your soul is restored
tour to you I can't say that I've been
going around pouring it on graves and
the people have risen back to life I
can't say that because that would be a
violation of the truth but if I could
say that I would so check it out $59 a
year you get the annual subscription you
just want to listen later for free go
over to iTunes go over to YouTube
subscribe leave us a review really
appreciate that's the best way to help
the company and help our show really
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
all righty so now I want to talk to you
about the stupidest judicial ruling I
have seen in a long long and time so a
federal judge ruled Wednesday morning
according to law and crime calm that
President Donald Trump may not block
critics on Twitter so many of those
critics must now be unblocked hey for
those who don't know Hut Twitter works
the way it works is that you send off
your little missus into cyberspace and
anyone can see them unless that person
annoys you in which case you have the
ability to do one of two things you can
either mute them so you can't see their
responses to you this is my preferred
method because I just am amused by the
idea that there are people who are so
upset about what I'm saying that they
are firing back tweet after tweet at me
and I can't hear them at all it's the
equivalent of me pinning mute on my TV
screen or sticking my thumbs in my ears
I don't actually need to listen to you
and you still think you're talking to me
so I think that's really funny but
there's also block okay the block
function is where you can't even see my
tweets so I don't believe I've actually
used the block button on anyone on
Twitter if I have like one or two people
maybe the president Trump has over the
years blocked a lot of people and there
are lots of legislators who have I am
blocked by a number of Hollywood
celebrities a number of Democrats have
blocked me as well that is not a shock
because they don't want you seeing their
tweets and then mocking them right
particularly you have a big following
because you know I have 1.4 million
followers on Twitter and so that gives
me the ability to someone tweet
something stupid tweet out about their
tweet and then it's not good for them so
in any case there's a lawsuit filed
against Trump for blocking people on
Twitter here's why this is dumb first of
all you can still view any of Donald
Trump's tweets simply by going to
twitter.com and not logging in if you
don't log in and you just view his
Twitter feed you can do that without
actually having to count on Twitter a
second are we really suggesting the
media don't cover Trump's Twitter feed
is the suggestion here that you have no
access to what Donald Trump said if you
are if you are not unblocked by
President Trump and Twitter is not a
public utility right Twitter is a method
for distribution so this would seem to
suggest that if the President of the
United States gives an interview to one
outlet he must give an interview to all
outlets you can't give an exclusive
anymore instead every outlet must be
welcome welcomed into the White House
press office every time Trump has a
press conference well obviously this is
stupid a 75-page order US District Judge
Naomi Rice Buckwald concisely began her
lengthy analysis with the following
emphatic finding of the law this case
require us requires us to consider
whether a public official made
consistent
the first amendment block a person from
his Twitter account in response to the
political views that person has
expressed and whether the analysis
difference because that public official
is the President of the United States
the answer to both questions is no and
she says we hold that portions of the
real Donald Trump accounts the
interactive space where Twitter users
may directly engage with the content of
the president's tweets are properly
analyzed under the public forum
doctrines set forth by the Supreme Court
and that such space is a designated
public forum and at the blocking of the
plaintiffs based on their political
speech constitutes viewpoint
discrimination that violates the First
Amendment well
Twitter owns Trump's account Twitter
could shut down his account tomorrow he
doesn't own Twitter can Twitter is not a
public forum he doesn't pay tax dollars
to Twitter again this is this is
completely idiotic and if this is the
case then presumably I should sue all
the Democratic legislators who have been
blocking me
but antipathy for the antipathy for the
the Trump administration has led the
judiciary just to the stupidest possible
conclusions like really really dumb
conclusions what they say is that under
Supreme Court jurisprudence there are
three types of public forums for aa
traditional designated and limited and
closed so they found that this is a
designated public forum because anyone
can viewed from streets because anyone
with the Twitter account can follow
Trump's tweets because anyone who's not
blocked on swear it can interact with
Trump's tweets and because the social
media directly said social media
director at the White House dance Covino
said Twitter is how Trump communicates
with you the American people again
Twitter is a private company Twitter is
not a public forum but this is how
stupid the judiciary has become now
speaking of Twitter and stupidity
Michael avenatti you remember him this
is the lawyer for stormy Daniels and he
is the great leader of the Democratic
Party now he is the great white hope to
take down President Trump Trump will
fall thanks to the bravery and supreme
leadership of Michael avenatti and
stormy Daniels she will cast her spells
from the witches of breast wick and
president Trump will immediately be cast
out of office well now it turns out that
Michael avenatti is a coward so he has
now made his accounts on Twitter box
he's locked it he's made it a private
account he has like six hundred thousand
followers on Twitter and he blocked his
entire account so presumably I can sue
Michael avenatti since this is the way
he gets out information and I can make
the claim that Michael avenatti
is not able to block me because Twitter
is a public forum so does public just
like in a public park he can't force me
to be removed from a public park Kenny
he says I purposely locked my account
due to the following due to the
following
but abusive trolls and we will be
releasing some sensitive info in the
coming weeks and I want to somewhat
control who has initial access to it
you're not going to control who has
initial access to it dude you have six
hundred thousand followers on Twitter
and a lot of those people presumably are
going to distribute that information as
soon as it hits Ryan Lizza CNN rightly
said this is ridiculous he rightly said
this hypocritical how can you say that
he's a champion in the press when at the
same time he's blocking reporters who
are covering him after there were mildly
critical tweets but again it's hypocrisy
thy name be left ISM and the hypocrisy
of the left is on full display
throughout all of this just silliness
and and this this Twitter spat is really
particularly stupid I mean the fact that
that Trump tweets things out and that
people look at those tweets does not
mean that you have direct access to
president Trump's every thought anytime
regardless as to who you are or that you
have no access to Trump if you can't
follow him on Twitter I promise you
people are pretty aware of what
President Trump is doing these days but
it shows the perversion of the judiciary
and the fact that the judges that
President Trump is selecting are deeply
important because once the judiciary is
monopolized by the left then they will
use that judiciary to cram down what
other whatever dumb policy they see fit
to cram down that day okay meanwhile the
the Muller investigation continues to
move forward the latest on that is that
Muller is planning on sentencing George
papadopolis you remember George
papadopolis he's a former Trump campaign
aide the case that was being made by the
Obama administration the FBI the DOJ
under Obama is that it was scrutiny of
George papadopolis that led to the
opening of the Trump Russia collusion
investigation because Papadopoulos had
met with a professor in London who had
said that that that he had access to
Hillary Clinton's emails via Russian
hacking and Papadopoulos had gone around
bragging about it this is what led to
the opening of the investigation
according to the FBI
well now apparently according to CNN
reporter Shimon Procope esque he says
that the that the the Muller office has
asked the courts to begin the sentencing
process he says it signals to now they
are done with George papadopolis in his
cooperation
he's been providing them information for
months now cooperating with them within
the last hour the special counsels
office filed a status report saying
they're ready for him to be sentenced
and they are ready so this does not
really go Sun indicator as to what
exactly he knew or when he knew it or
what this means for
in Trump the Muller investigation
continues apace now one of the things
that's hilarious about all of this is
that it is quite plausible it is quite
plausible impossible the modeler
investigation comes up with nothing the
latest indicator that they could come up
with nothing is Jared Kushner so Jared
Kushner as you recall his president
Trump's son-in-law he's also a top
adviser to President Trump he's run his
Middle East policy and his China policy
and his toilet replacement policy and
pretty much every other policy a lot of
the policy considerations go through
Kushner's office I think some of them
beyond his brief but he's done a good
job on the Middle East so I'm happy with
that in any case Jared Kushner he has
been very cooperative with Robert Muller
and you recall that just a few months
ago his his clearance his top-secret
security clearance was revoked by John
Kelly who's the White House chief of
staff because he had a temporary top
security clearance and that was revoked
after there was a staffer who was ousted
from the White House for having
allegedly abused his ex-wife and
ex-girlfriends remember that whole story
well after that John Kelly revoked the
temporary top-secret clearances of a
bunch of people including Jared Kushner
and a bunch of people in the president
this must be because Kushner's corrupt
it must be because Kushner's corrupt
well now Koecher has his top-secret
security clearance back so so much for
the whole he's so corrupt he can't get
top-secret clearance back routine he's
got his top-secret clearance back not
only that he was given his top-secret
clearance back after he's been
interviewed by robert muller twice for
seven hours
here's Kushner's lawyer explaining i
don't know that anybody could be
cooperating more he has spoken to them
when asked he has provided them with
tons of documents that reflect what he's
provided Congress and what else they
have asked for he sat down in the fall
when they wanted to ask questions about
general Flynn and he was very happy to
spend almost an entire workday when they
asked again so I would say it's the
definition of cooperation so yeah the
assumption on the part of the left is
that Jared Kushner was gonna go to jail
but there was too much corruption he was
gonna go to jail that's why he could
didn't have his top secret clearance
that obviously was false
and not only was that false Kushner has
sat down with Robert Miller on more than
one occasion and everything is fine for
him so I think that a lot of the left
narrative about
Moniz gonna get Trump it's all gonna
fall apart for him I think a lot of that
is falling apart now with that said I
still am skeptical of President Trump
story that he was unfairly targeted by
the
f.b.eye at the beginning of 2016 I'm
still very skeptical of this I don't see
why if he was targeted by the FBI he
doesn't just declassify the documents
demonstrating this the President of the
United States has plenary power to
declassify anything he wants under FBI
auspices so that means tonight he could
just get rid of the of the
classification status for the FISA
warrant on Carter page he could just get
rid of the classification status on all
the information about the informant
against his campaign and again I am Not
sure that can we have to be very
specific in our language when president
Trump says that he was spied on his
campaign was spied on members of his
campaign had an informants against them
that's not quite the same thing as
saying that Trump himself was spied on
or Kushner was spied on or Bannon was
spied on or any of the top members of
his campaign at any point low-level
people who were openly discussing the
possibility of working with Russia it
seems to me were the targets of the
informants the reason I'm being careful
here is just I want to go over the
evidence ladies if the evidence ends up
leading to spy gates 2018 fine
fine if that's where it leads I'm happy
to go there but so far I'm not seeing
the evidence and I want to be very
specific before we start slandering the
entire FBI and suggesting the FBI was
out to get Trump in March 2016 before he
had even won the nomination okay so you
know let's just be specific in our
accusations okay I think that it's time
for some things I like and then some
things that I hate so anything that I
like today so I have been watching this
stars series I guess an old star series
went 2013-2014 with Rebecca Hamilton
who's become a relatively major star she
was in life with Jake Gyllenhaal she's
in a bunch of other stuff now as well
and the the this is a miniseries the
White Queen the White Queen is about the
period in English history this is like
14 70s 1480s the period in English
history British history in which there
it's the War of the Roses this is the
period covering Edward the fourth
Richard the third who you'll recall from
your Shakespeare classes in high school
if you actually went to a decent high
school and then the period immediately
following with the restoration of Henry
the fourth so yes and Ray forth so that
is hundred six okay in any case the the
series is quite good it's really well
produced it stars that means there's a
little bit of boobage for no apparent
reason so just be warned about that if
that's something that bothers you but
the but the production quality is
excellent it is it is really worth
watching and the portrayal of Richard
the third is really interesting because
it is exactly counselor to the
Shakespearean portrayal of Richard the
third so remember that Richard the third
was the last of the Plantagenet and at
the time the Shakespeare was writing
which is two hundred years after the
well let's see when was Shakespeare
writing I don't know I'm gonna have to
check it out so Shakespeare was writing
within the next century right
Shakespeare was writing in the late 1500
he's about a hundred years later and
he's writing after this and the current
regime in Britain it's Elizabeth
Elizabethan England Elizabethan England
is a spawn of the line that followed
Richard the third right so remember that
the the House of Lancaster has recovered
its predominance by the time that
Shakespeare is writing and the Richard
the thirds family his entire family was
the the was was the not the not the it
was the last of the Plantagenet so it
was it was the Lancaster's versus the
York says the York family so the York
family was fighting the fighting the
Lancaster's for predominance the
Lancaster's ended up winning
Shakespeare's writing under a Lancaster
Queen Queen Elizabeth and what this
would result in in his work is this real
bias against Richard the third Witcher
that there is an evil guy who killed his
nephews and and all the rest I'm gonna
have to recommend a book probably next
time on Richard the third
that sort of debunk this but this series
sort of debunked it as well so here's a
little bit of the preview for the White
Queen Elizabeth great oh great
the king has done what he should not he
has married from another house and a
commoner at that from many who will be
wishing us to fall making it sound more
like a battle than a marriage it is a
battle she could never be Roy she's my
queen of choice this can easily be
undone it wasn't crazy what it brings
ten thousand men from the south okay so
the the series is actually really well
shaded you don't get the idea that any
one of these people is like the great
hero although Richard the third is
treated very sympathetically
production-quality very very high
it was Henry the seventh by the way who
was the who was the successor to Richard
the third
obviously you remember from Shakespeare
class my horse my horse my kingdom for a
horse that comes from Richard the third
that last battle that is what the series
approach is near the end but it's really
well drawn the acting is quite good the
scripting is quite good well worth
watching very sympathetic take on on
virtually all of the characters so
definitely worth checking out ok are now
time for a quick thing that I hate ok so
here is the thing that I hate today the
thing that I hate is that there's a
Freedom of Information request Act
request that was reported by the
Baltimore Post about Barack Obama and
his top advisors after the tragedy at
Sandy Hook ok right after the tragedy at
Sandy Hook after the active evil at
Sandy Hook in which 20 children were
shot and 6 staffers were shot as well to
death the the top members of the Obama
administration immediately began
discussing how to use this as a
political weapon before the bodies were
even cold ok so two days after the
massacre the left 26 dead there's a text
exchange between Chicago Mayor Rahm
Emanuel former chief of staff for
President Obama and Education Secretary
Arne Duncan about what to do and they
were discussing so Duncan said what are
your thoughts in the subject line CT
shooting and Emanuel said go for a vote
this week ASAP before it fades tap
people's emotion make it simple assault
weapons yep thanks for applied the
education secretary and then Emanuel
wrote back when I did Brady bill and
assault weapons for Clinton we always
made it simple criminals or war weapons
and then Duncan asked about so-called
gun show loopholes
he said gun show loophole database
cop-killer bullets too complicated said
Emanuel cop killer may be answered
Emanuel the other no got it Duncan
agreed so they were already
ideas on how exactly to take advantage
of this entire thing the immediate
polarization the immediate
politicization the attempt to turn it
into a rallying cry for gun control
tap people's emotions is you know listen
that's politics
but when it's exposed to public view it
is a little bit gross it is a little bit
gross and I think everybody should see
that the supposed sincerity of the Obama
administration and pushing legislation
connected with gun control was largely
about tapping into people's emotion
which you could tell certainly at the
time okay we'll be back here tomorrow
with mailbag so if you're gonna
subscribe now is the day to do it
because this means that you get to be
part of our mailbag tomorrow check it
out and over at daily wire and if you
want to join our events in Phoenix or
Dallas go to Daley wired.com slash
events check us out as well on Apple
news we always appreciate it we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the bench Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
Vera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018